do you ever think about the unknown as
it pertains to bitcoin you know like
what is the bitcoin risk you know blah
blah blah and i promise i'm not trying
to spread fud but i'm just saying what
are your questions let's just go right
through all your bitcoin questions i
mean i don't know do you ever think
about the un no if you said to me right
now let's do we'll do first the bear
case for bitcoin then we'll talk about
the bull case the bear case for bitcoin
would be it's a global store of value
today it's obvious that people have
adopted this grown into a
trillion-dollar asset but uh unlike what
the bitcoin proponents believe bitcoin
won't cross over into becoming a
currency and therefore that will
drastically hamper kind of the
addressable market the most it can grow
to is gold which is basically a store of
value isn't really used for uh to go
purchase things on a day-to-day basis
and therefore yes there may be more
upside but it's kind of a capped upside
the second one is uh eventually we're
gonna figure out who satoshi is and if
we figure out who satoshi is that's
gonna be a bad person and we're not
gonna wanna know who it is and like
there's gonna be negative uh impact the
next thing is nobody's using it for uh
specific use cases like uh being able to
actually do cross-border payments all
stuff it's slow it's expensive it's kind
of all these like technical issues with
it and then there's an argument of uh
the unknown of like the government's
gonna clamp down on the future yeah i
don't think they can show that they're
gonna regulate it they're gonna tax it
they're gonna shut it down they're gonna
outlaw it they're gonna do all this
stuff if you take every single one of
those things
none of them are a zero percent chance
but what is the odd two percent on each
of those and i'm not even talking about
those i'm just
you know maybe it's totally uneducated
it's just
one thing that gives me a little bit of
trepidation is i trust elon musk a lot
and
you look at his conviction around
bitcoin versus dorsey and it it just it
makes you think you know
what are his thoughts on i mean i know
he don't he owns a lot though right
from what i understand it's a material
part of his net worth personally on top
of some maybe
maybe he's look maybe he's
yeah
i think i think the
best argument somebody could make and
what i think is the biggest risk to
bitcoin it really pisses the critics off
because it has nothing to do with
anything external
there's still a development process
there is still a upgrade process to
bitcoin and it's incredibly methodical
it's incredibly intentional it's slow on
purpose lots of kind of filters and
security checks etc
but technically a code uh there could be
a bug in the code that's introduced yeah
and so i guess like shooting yourself in
the foot right could that happen or i
mean anything i mean literally you know
and though electricity in the world
could shut off because uh meteor hit the
earth but if you think about it the
governments can't shut it down can't
have nuclear war shut it down right i
mean i guess i mean you have to have
nuclear bombs all across the world right
i mean and even then you probably still
win now there's still going to be one
computer somewhere that is running that
software it's kind of like elon last
night somebody was saying like oh should
the government shut it down or i don't
know and he's like he's like
they can't or something what did he say
yeah we were talking about it um they
basically said that they can't they they
can't kill bitcoin yeah right you know
to be clear i don't i own a lot like
because it
because in dollars it makes me think
like wow i own a lot of bitcoin like i
should really make sure i know what the
hell is going on with this thing and i
think i've done the due diligence but i
own a little over 10 percent which is
not a lot in terms of when you i mean
you own like what 95 of your net worth
in the damn thing yeah i mean so so when
i asked the question about the unknown
unknown and you know your mind could go
a zillion different directions it just
how do you get the confidence to go from
10 to
95
your 10
is in the new digital financial system
yep
you're 90 in the legacy financial system
i think of uh the risk
spectrum in let's call the crypto
industry
on the far left you have the least risky
asset bitcoin it is kind of the uh the
the blue chip largest most decentralized
longest track record et cetera a
thousand percent in crypto least risky
most conservative asset on the other end
of the spectrum you have
crazy things that people are coming up
with all kinds of tokens and uh schemes
and innovations and and experiments and
whatever that you can go buy for a penny
right so you have on one end super
conservative on the other end you have
super risky when you look at the crypto
industry what most people are doing is
they come into the industry and the
people who end up going way out on the
risk curve they literally say oh yeah of
course bitcoin's going to work
but i want better returns than bitcoin
they're chasing something that is higher
or better performing than bitcoin alone
and so what
i think about is the reason why bitcoin
is so attractive is i actually don't
need to have the best returning ass i
don't need to be greedy
i want the thing that has a great
economic return
but also i know it's going to be around
in 50 years so let me ask you do you
have anxiety about not putting the rest
of your five percent in bitcoin no
because a lot of that ends up being uh
and when i use percentage is usually
liquid net worth i've got cash and then
uh i still make some private investments
as well so
in some crazy way like if i invest in a
company that then uh is using the
lightning network like
it's not bitcoin exposure but you know
it's pretty close it's uh it's
definitely related if you compare
what i just talked about in the crypto
world of like conservative on one end
super risky on the other end of the
crypto industry
if you look at the regular financial
world like the legacy financial world
bitcoin is the most risky asset you
could buy right and then like maybe
bonds or cash or something is unlike the
other end and so
the beauty of sitting in like that
bitcoin
seat
is that all of the crypto guys and girls
who are like way out on the wrist curve
they're like this is like the most like
what are you doing right like that's not
gonna drive you great returns yeah they
call you a boomer yeah yeah
but the legacy finance world like i go
talk to you know big hedge funds right
they're like what are you doing like
that is the craziest thing i've ever
heard yeah that's actually probably
where you want to be i agree right like
i know there's way crazier things that
you could do in the world
but i also know that there's way safer
things you could do in the world so like
but 95 is very respectable you don't say
that that often do you i mean i hear you
say it once in a while yeah i mean it's
uh
it sounds like a crazy number until you
just say no i just denominate my life
and my portfolio in bitcoin so it's no
different than dollars right if you have
uh a hundred percent most people right
in dollars in dollar denominated bonds
or dollar denominated assets you
essentially have 100 exposure to what i
think of as the legacy financial world
and so
if you ask me right now gun to my head
which financial world has the most room
to grow moving forward well the legacy
world is like we've had it for you know
100 plus years right like it's been here
there's just not that much future growth
to it
versus we get this crazy stuff and
that's why like the stock market was
freaking out over two percent drop right
i mean literally right now bitcoin could
drop five percent and no one would even
care it's just like yeah of course it
goes up and down you know three five ten
percent a day are you surprised it's not
higher now
i don't know if i'm necessarily
surprised it's not higher
hindsight bias is real strong because
you kind of understand why it's not
higher
but i would be very surprised if it
doesn't go much higher through the end
of this year like if if we didn't at
least get a new all-time high something
happened that uh i either didn't
understand didn't foresee uh or um
uh
j just
missed right
all-time high is only 20k it's like a 50
move from here which again sounds crazy
in legacy terms in bitcoin crypto world
like you know that's like could happen
in a week um and then on top of that
it's like once it breaks through the
all-time high like where does it go
i mean we've had how many people come on
and you hear everything from 80
to somebody recently said 400 000 this
year like yeah and and they all have a
good explanation and you're like yeah
all 80 to 400 000 is all possible right
it's funny so we'll see how do you think
about uh buying uh stocks versus like
more bitcoin or anything that's like
more like alternative investor private
markets well i've been thinking about
upping my percent of bitcoin uh
so i've recently gone over that 10
amount and it's growing because
it's getting
bigger you know but
um do you rebalance that's another thing
that i see a lot of institutions love to
rebalance
but in some weird way you're basically
taking your best performers and you're
cutting your exposure
versus just
make the investments and then just let
them turn into whatever they do yeah not
really i mean in the early days i was
selling a little bit of bitcoin but that
was because
uh it just went up so quick that you
were just like what the you know what is
going on here you know and i always get
worried about the psychological
phenomena of like confirmation bias and
it's like okay like yeah i think it's
going up because i know why it's going
up but do i really know why it's going
up and it keeps just
going you know so
so no i don't really imagine being one
of these guys that has a billion dollars
on it or you know five billion dollars
of it and it keeps going up right it's
since you must think you're a genius
it gets pretty crazy right i mean joe
and john is uh the best story i think
we've told on this on
the show before is joe uh called me one
day and uh john had bought bitcoin i
think i don't know whatever it was and
he goes yo you got to talk to john and i
was like why and he's like john said he
ain't gonna make it to 20k is that like
11. and i was like what do you mean he
goes yeah he said dude this thing goes
to 20 i'm selling and now what percent
of your guys money do you have in it a
very similar amount
95 yeah how about you uh yeah i'm
probably in the i got to do some
calculations but i'm probably in like
the 90s
i hope i don't buy more today but but
here's the point here but here's what we
have to remember is
it's also different when you're younger
when like yeah but i'm 33 right and i
see it and i see bitcoin in his play you
know as plain as day right
yeah i don't understand people who don't
see it
but
john i think that's the light bulb right
it's like once you realize that and you
you think of it in the context of like
it's inevitable right to some degree uh
you start aggressively figuring out how
you can acquire more right and knowing
that it's constrained supply all you're
looking at is the demand
becomes a no-brainer no but seriously
the reason that i take it so seriously
is not just because of my own family and
and you know trying to provide for my
family with money but if i can figure
out how to compound to our point earlier
returns over a period of time
you know
my capital i look at it is helping fuel
a lot of this transaction volume that's
going across twitter for the poverty
angle so
it's it's a very helpful discussion i
completely agree what's up guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today if we're going
to be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more of the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]